- [Devin] Thanks to Skillshare
for keeping LegalEagle in the air.
Learn to think like a lawyer
for free for two months
by clicking the link in the description.
Attorney General William Barr
wrote a four page summary
of the Mueller report.
Here are the nine reasons I
don't think it makes any sense.
(soaring trumpet music)
Hey, Legal Eagles.
Today, we're talking
about the Barr Letter.
This is not the Mueller Report,
as a lot of people have reported.
This is a summary of the Mueller Report
as conveyed by the Attorney General.
The Barr Letter purports to summarize
the findings of Special
Counsel Robert Mueller
and his investigation
into the Trump campaign
and potential ties to
Russian interference with our election.
When the Barr Letter came out on Sunday,
I, like many Americans,
read it cover to cover.
But there were a couple things
that stuck out to me as an attorney
that just didn't make any sense.
So, here are the nine
things that I don't think
make any sense in the Barr Letter.
Number one: Why does the
Barr Letter only cover
two of the three facets
of the Mueller Report?
You might recall that
Robert Mueller was tasked
with investigating three things.
A criminal investigation into
potential ties with Russia,
a criminal investigation into potential
obstruction of justice by the President,
and number three, a
counter-intelligence investigation
into Russian interference
with the American election.
But the Barr Letter only deals with
two of the three facets
of the Mueller Report
and doesn't actually deal with
the counter-intelligence portions
of the Mueller Investigation.
Why is that information
missing from Barr's letter?
Barr could have easily provided a summary
of the counter-intelligence
portion of the investigation,
but for some reason, he chose not to.
Why is that information not there?
And we also learned that
Barr is going to make
a separate summary that can only be given
to the Gang of Eight instead of the full
Intelligence Committees in
the House and the Senate.
So, why is there information
that can only be provided
to the Gang of Eight when a summary,
even a top-level summary,
can't be provided
in the letter that is released
to Congress in general
and to the American people?
Number two: What does Barr mean
when he says that the
Mueller Report, quote,
"did not establish", end quote,
a conspiracy with the Russians?
What does it mean to not
establish in this context?
The Barr Letter quotes a
portion of the Mueller Report
stating that, quote, "The
investigation did not establish
"that members of the
Trump Campaign conspired
"or coordinated with
the Russian government
"in its election
interference activities.".
The problem is that this phrase
can mean wildly different things.
Does it mean that there
was no evidence at all
or does it mean that there
is a boatload of evidence
but there is not quite enough to meet
the standard of beyond a reasonable doubt
that is necessary for
a criminal prosecution?
If a prosecutor says that an investigation
did not establish something,
it doesn't mean that that
thing did not happen.
It doesn't even mean that
the prosecutor doesn't think it happened.
It means that the investigation
didn't produce enough information
to prove beyond a reasonable doubt
in front of a jury that
that thing happened.
So, in this particular context,
we don't know which of those
potential outcomes there is.
Is it that there is absolutely no evidence
or that there is evidence,
but not quite enough
to meet the legal standard
for a criminal prosecution?
The difference between those
two things is incredibly large
and is very important as it regards
what Congress is supposed to do next
with this investigation.
Number three: Why does Barr suggest
that there can be no
obstruction of justice
when there isn't a conviction
for an underlying crime?
Attorney General Barr
suggests in his letter
that you cannot have a conviction
of obstruction of justice
when there is no underlying criminal act
or a conviction for an
underlying criminal act,
but that's simply not the case.
A conviction for an
underlying criminal act
is not necessary for a conviction
of obstruction of justice.
Just talk to Martha Stewart, Barry Bonds,
Bill Clinton, or Kwame Kilpatrick.
The last example is
especially illustrative
because former Detroit
Mayor Kwame Kilpatrick
went to jail for obstruction of justice
in 2008 after he lied under oath
about having an extramarital affair.
Having an affair is not an illegal act
but it's often embarrassing,
especially for politicians,
and they can go to jail
for obstructing justice
to prevent that information
from coming out.
This is especially
worrying because Barr wrote
a now famous, perhaps infamous,
19 page memo laying out
a very idiosyncratic view
of obstruction of justice.
In the 19 page memo,
Bar opined that, quote,
"The President's motive in removing Comey
"and commenting on Flynn
could not have been corrupt
"unless the President and his campaign
"were actually guilty
of illegal collusion.".
The vast majority of legal scholars agree
that this is simply not the case,
that even in the absence
of an actual guilty verdict
of illegal collusion or
conspiracy or coordination,
that is not necessary as a predicate
for obstructing justice
into that investigation.
But that brings me to point number four:
Why does Attorney General Barr think
that there was no crime?
Even taking Attorney General
Barr's idiosyncratic view
of obstruction of justice
at face value, even so,
there was crime that was found
in the Mueller Investigation
and throughout the investigations
into the President.
President Trump is effectively
an unindicted co-conspirator
in a felony campaign finance
violation with Michael Cohen.
Hiding, or at least
preventing, the investigation
into that embarrassing
affair and illegal conduct
is more than enough
reason to obstruct justice
and can give rise to
the corrupt mental state
necessary to be guilty of
obstruction of justice.
Potentially, that
investigation was farmed out
to the Southern District of New York,
but even still, that is
potential criminal conduct
that could give rise to
obstruction of justice.
Not to mention all of
the other convictions
of Papadopoulos, Manafort, and Flynn.
So, the question is why would Barr
or Mueller himself
limit the crime at issue
to the very narrow definition
of Russian conspiracy
that was talked about in the Barr Letter?
I don't think that makes any sense.
Which takes me to point number five:
Why didn't Robert Mueller
decide the obstruction issue?
The Barr Letter states that, quote,
"After making a thorough
factual investigation
"into these matters, the
Special Counsel considered
"whether to evaluate the conduct
under Department standards
"governing prosecution
and declination decisions
"but ultimately determined not to make
"a traditional prosecutorial judgment.
"The Special Counsel therefore
did not draw a conclusion
"one way or the other as to whether
"the examined conduct
constituted obstruction.".
That doesn't sounds like Robert Mueller
declined to prosecute because of the facts
or that there wasn't enough evidence,
but because of some
countervailing legal issue.
Perhaps because of the DOJ policy
not to indict the sitting President.
But the Barr Letter goes on to state that,
instead, for each of the
relevant actions investigated,
the report sets out evidence
on both sides of the question
and leaves unresolved what
the Special Counsel views
as difficult decisions of law and fact
concerning whether the
President's actions and intent
could be viewed as obstruction.
To me, that doesn't make any sense.
If the facts were 50/50, what
we call equipoise in the law,
that doesn't meet the standard
of beyond a reasonable doubt.
When there is some evidence but not enough
to reach the very high standard
of beyond a reasonable doubt,
then a prosecutor declines to prosecute.
In fact, Mueller
apparently did exactly this
with the collusion, coordination,
and conspiracy investigation,
which Barr summarizes
as finding that Mueller did not find
enough evidence to establish those crimes.
So, why did Robert Mueller punt
on the obstruction question
but not on the collusion
and conspiracy question?
Which brings me to the next
point, point number six:
Why did William Barr weigh
in on the obstruction issue?
William Barr is a recent
political appointee
by President Trump.
The point of the Special Counsel Statute
was for a neutral party to
investigate the executive branch.
If Robert Mueller found enough evidence
to convict someone for
obstruction of justice,
the Barr Letter appears to
state that Robert Mueller
did not decline to prosecute
for obstruction of justice
because there wasn't enough evidence,
but because of some other legal issue.
Then does that mean that
Robert Mueller intended
for William Barr to
weigh in on the question
or did Robert Mueller intend
for Congress to answer this question?
Was it intended to be teed up
for Congress to make that decision?
Declining to make a, quote,
"traditional prosecutorial decision"
is not necessarily inviting
the political appointee,
William Barr, to make that decision.
And on top of that, Robert
Mueller, as Special Counsel,
has exclusive jurisdiction in this matter.
Why did he decide not to move forward
with the obstruction prosecution?
We know that when Robert Mueller
does not find enough
evidence to prosecute,
he makes a decision not to prosecute.
But here, in the context
of obstruction of justice,
Robert Mueller is refusing to
make any decision whatsoever.
We will only know what that means
when the full Mueller Report is revealed.
And on top of that, how is it possible
that William Barr can make
this decision in 48 hours
when Robert Mueller couldn't
make the decision in two years?
And was William Barr even able to review
all of the underlying
evidence in this case?
We don't even know how long
the Mueller Report itself actually is.
Which brings me to point number seven:
Whose legal conclusions are these
and are there other legal conclusions
that we haven't seen yet?
The Barr Letter only purports to convey
Mueller's top-line findings
and does not include
any of the underlying evidence
or legal analysis that
undergirds those findings.
The Barr Letter talks about the two, quote
"principal findings"
of the Mueller Report,
but does that mean that there are
other legal findings
that Mueller concluded
that are not part of
these top-line findings?
And as to the legal
conclusions that we have,
we don't know whether
Attorney General Barr
concluded that the President
did not obstruction
justice as a factual matter
or that it wasn't legally possible
for him to have obstructed justice.
Again, going back to Barr's
unsolicited 19 page memo,
he argued a minority position
that a president effectively
cannot obstruct justice
when it comes to using
his Article II power.
And Barr also argued that
the obstruction of justice statutes
don't apply to the President
because they do not
specifically mention the President.
If Attorney General Barr imputed
those minority legal positions
onto Robert Mueller and the investigation,
then it was effectively
impossible, as a logical matter,
for the President to have
conducted obstruction of justice.
Which brings me to point number eight:
Why did Barr quote the
portion of the Mueller Report
that states that the Mueller Report
does not exonerate the President?
The Barr Letter is potential
partisan whitewashing.
We don't know what's in
the underlying report
and we don't know how
accurate of a summary
the Barr Letter actually is.
It's possible that Barr is
intentionally setting the narrative
before the full Mueller Report comes out.
But even still, why include
this cherry-picked phrase
that is actually detrimental
to the President,
stating that the Mueller Report does not,
in fact, exonerate the President?
If a report or evidence
doesn't exonerate someone from a crime
and you're writing a summary about it,
you don't have to include
a sentence that says,
"The report does not
exonerate that person.".
You can just leave it at the fact that
the crime was not established
or that the decision was
made not to prosecute.
You don't have to go to the extra step
and say that it doesn't
exonerate that person
and it seems like an odd inclusion
in this very high-level
summary of the Mueller Report.
Which takes me to point number nine,
which may be the most baffling
thing about the Barr Letter
and potentially, the
Mueller Report itself,
which is that there was a decision made
not to prosecute for
obstruction of justice,
but that decision was made
without interviewing the President.
Was there an effort to actually
interview the President?
We know that under past precedent,
under the Clinton versus Jones affair
and also the Starr investigation
into President Clinton
that the President can be made
to stand for an interview.
Was an effort to get President Trump
to stand for an interview made?
And on top of that,
why allow the President
to offer written answers
to written questions
in lieu of an actual oral examination?
Obstruction of justice requires
proving that the defendant
had a corrupt motive
in conducting the acts
that constitute the
obstruction of justice.
The best way to determine that
is to interview the defendant.
Now, potentially, the defendant can
take the Fifth Amendment, but here,
given that the best evidence
one way or the other
is going to come from the
President about his motivations
in taking these different actions,
why was the President not
interviewed in this investigation?
Now that the investigation is done,
Attorney General Barr is going to have to
read through thousands of
pages of the Mueller Report
to determine what can
be publicly released.
He could really benefit
from a speed reading class
to get through the full
Mueller Report quickly,
like Silviu Marisca's Skillshare
class on speed reading,
which could teach Barr
to triple his reading speed in seven days.
Silviu's class could teach Barr
how to read the Mueller Report
at a thousand words per
minute and at the same time,
improve his reading
comprehension and retention.
At that rate, we might
actually see the Mueller Report
before the next presidential election.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that has over 20,000
classes on everything,
like lifestyle, design,
technology, business, you name it.
The first 500 Legal Eagles will get
two free months of Skillshare
when you click on the link below.
The free premium membership gives you
unlimited access to must-know topics
so you can improve your
skills and learn new things.
So, click on the link,
get two free months,
and start learning to
think like a lawyer today.
It could even help you
read the Mueller Report
and figure out why he refused
to make the call on obstruction.
Do you agree?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out my other
real law reviews over here
where I will see you in court.